also breaking overnight former president
Trump's long effort to keep his tax
returns hidden is coming to an end
Congress had big stacks of documents
wheeled in as house Democrats voted to
finally make those returns public Scott
McFarland is on Capitol Hill with more
on what we have learned Scott good
morning
hey naked morning it's the final chapter
of an epic legal battle over the former
president's tax returns a house
committee having won a victory at the
Supreme Court plans to release six years
of tax filings of Trumps by the end of
this week and this morning we're also
learning of a major reported failure by
the IRS
Mr chairman on this vote I have 24 yays
16 no's the U.S House Ways and Means
Committee voted Tuesday night straight
down party lines to make former
president Donald Trump's tax returns
public overnight the panel released a
committee report about its probe and its
initial review of the tax papers
revealing among other things the IRS did
not do the mandatory presidential audits
of trump during his first two years in
office and never completed any audits
while he served they quickly concluded
that in fact
the audit did not occur that's despite
Trump's perennial claims he couldn't
share his taxes with the public because
he was under audit no I've been under
audit for so many years every year I get
audited according to the committee
report tax forms show that Trump's
reported more losses than gains in six
years since 2015 and paid little to no
federal income taxes between 2015 and
2020. something he bragged about during
the presidential debate against Hillary
Clinton and they showed he didn't pay
any federal income tax so that makes me
smart Trump supporters in Congress call
the release an abuse of power and
overreach by democrats will be losing
control of the U.S house in less than
two weeks this Committee Action will set
a terrible precedent that unleashes a
dangerous new political weapon that
reaches far beyond the former president
Trump's campaign calls the release of
the taxes of political attack still the
committee has raised questions about
whether Trump had the proper
documentation for the deductions he
sought and also CBS News has reached out
to the IRS for comment about this report
and we have yet to get a response Gail
what we're hearing is very revealing
thank you very much Scott